E aí
[Música]
e essa é a segunda vez que eu tô subindo
aqui antes foi na universidade agora
numa pandemia na primeira vez eu estava
muito nervosa só na primeira vez e
procure um sorriso na plateia para mim
salvar que o Senhorzinho sentado logo na
frente todo sorridente porque nele no
final ele veio me cumprimentar Parabéns
pela sua fala sou o reitor da UFRJ Ainda
bem que ele falou só no final e lá se
foram quase dez anos hoje eu só tenho
uma tela para olhar Espero que do outro
lado eu encontro sorrisos Olá eu sou uma
mulher de negócios sempre fui aos cinco
anos de idade eu criei meu primeiro
cartão de visita meu negócio vai fazer
show de mágica na garagem de casa minha
mãe infelizmente não deixava cobrar
minha irmã na época era minha ajudante
de mágica
começava ali o meu espírito de liderança
feminina
é um dia desse eu tava na internet
acompanha um posto de rede social
polêmico e vi um escritor renomado
retrucar uma seguidora que reclamavam o
direito das mulheres de falar a resposta
dele foi esse é o problema de vocês
vocês só querem ser ouvidos e ele tem
razão esse é o nosso problema nós
queremos ser ouvidas serão vida é um
privilégio Principalmente nos dias de
hoje o que vocês pensam como recebem um
áudio de 5 minutos no WhatsApp
podcast que louca não vão vir ainda bem
que Deus inventou o botão acelerar nós
mulheres temos bilhões de minutos
guardando a nossa voz que foi silenciada
os direitos negados e sonhos reprimidos
e esse áudio a gente não pode acelerar
vocês lembram da primeira voz que vocês
ouviram a primeira voz que ouvimos é
feminina da nossa mãe a voz de uma
mulher é a primeira que você vai ouvindo
a sua vida a vida trouxe isso para gente
e é da voz para uma mulher e silenciamos
a mulher
antes de me preparar para gravar hoje
para excitar x uma das coisas que eu
sempre penso sobre a sobre me preparar
para uma palestra é como eu faço para
ser ouvida
eu gosto de chamar atenção para os meus
olhos porque quando a gente olha nos
olhos das pessoas a gente ouvir mais do
que quando olha para a boca por isso eu
escolho óculos que chamem atenção mas a
cor do meu batom não deveria diminuir o
valor das minhas palavras
eu uso óculos desde pequena Sou míope
naquela época usar óculos era coisa de
nerd hoje é Crush Que bom quando era
apenas uma garota nerd eu me preocupado
em estudar muito mas as mulheres mesmo
tendo muito mais estudo que os homens
ainda ganham menos
E aí
estudar eu também gostava de dançar eu
fiz ballet Jazz sapateado
mas eu sentia vergonha eu vi as pessoas
dançando achava lindo mas eu entendi
aqui uma mulher ou dança ou tem futuro
na vida minha mãe queria ser bailarina
ela nunca me pediu de dançar mas só hoje
eu consigo entender que posso liberar
uma empresa conduzir negócios de sucesso
e dançar livremente
como eu professor de dança eu comecei a
entender porque eu tinha medo da
exposição corporal na dança
nos primeiros registros de dança famosos
é um mito de Salomé onde ela dança para
pedir a cabeça de João Batista um dos
mais famosos porque está no livro mais
lido de todos os tempos a Bíblia a dança
nesse caso é construída como uma imagem
sexualmente imoral
e por exemplo Para Louvar a Deus
desenvolvida por Davi eu não sei quem
escreveu o mito de Salomé mas ouso dizer
que não deve ter sido uma mulher
na Rússia e no mundo a validação da
dança como arte só veio quando um homem
passou a ter mais evidência no balé
O que
você já repararam como é preciso um
homem qualificar algo como sendo arte
para que se torne efetivamente arte e
para quem vir uma mulher possa conceber
prazer naquela atividade sem significar
promiscuidade ou utilidade e assim o
homem passa a qualificar diversas
atividades que antes eram feitas pelas
mulheres tornando-as importante e
rentável e o homem qualifica na cozinha
virando o chefe mas a minha avó era
cozinheira mesmo na dança no salão de
beleza da pintura gênios da pintura o
mente Van Gogh gogan amor e quando o
homem experimento uma profissão ele
passa a deter o destaque e o dinheiro eu
vou pedir para vocês fazer uma reflexão
Quantas vezes você já teve uma mulher
como chefe
e o consubstanciado no cargo de
liderança na sua empresa agora e ao seu
lado e mulheres pretas e
e hoje a gente vivia era onde é muito
mais importante cedo que ter a era das
marcas empresas e pessoas inspiradoras
mas nós mulheres Ainda precisamos ter
para si e ainda assim nem sempre
conseguimos a liberdade para ser que
para gozar o ser
a gozar
possuir utilizar algo prazeroso salutar
útil desde fritar aproveitar-se
e sem licença para gozar um duplo
sentido não deveríamos precisar de
licença para gozar e não temos até hoje
licença para gozar livremente a mulher
cresce sem o direito de gozar o direito
de ser uma mulher de sucesso de gozar a
sua multiplicidade de ser livre por
outro lado o homem pode gozar o sucesso
dele e ele sempre pode eu fui só se
arruma mente fundei outra a primeira 21
Pet do Brasil por dentro depois eu sair
por diversos motivos entre eles
divergência de igualdade de gênero
nessa posição e como se ou de duas
empresas eu ouvi coisas com você não
acha que são muito pratinhos para uma
mulher segurar
é sobre muitos pratinhos e sobre
habilidades múltiplas gostaria de trazer
uma curiosidade
vocês sabiam que o clitóris tem oito mil
terminações nervosas
engraçado de tudo isso é que quando o
homem goza acabou
mas a mulher pode ter um gás nos
múltiplos como que não vai poder segurar
Monte patins na verdade desde sempre nós
mulheres carregamos muitos pratinhos
sozinhos
gozar é permitir uma conexão profunda
com tudo que você é e representa é sobre
liberdade para ser tudo que você mulher
deseja A partir dessa Minha experiência
como sócio invente feliz e depois de
durar mais de 100 startups entre elas
diversas com falta as mulheres de baixa
renda eu desenvolvi um que eu chamo de
cão vejo protagonismo feminino O cão vai
ser uma ferramenta visual para organizar
e o negócio Oi e para ajudar esse
movimento da mulher vive preocupar com
sucesso os lugares que ela quiser o que
eu vejo protagonismo feminino funciona
como uma ferramenta para olhar você
mulher como um negócio de sucesso
nesse Campo mas eu trago oito um número
simbólico simbólico a áreas que eu uso e
que me ajudam a transformar a teoria sem
prática vamos ao primeiro espaço que
pode parecer um pouco polêmico número um
mulheres usem calças com bolsos
elogie-se é sobre saber os seus valores
os primeiros presente que minha mãe deu
como nos seus primeiros Salários para
minha avó foi uma calça minha avó tinha
varizes nas pernas e a calça protegia
esse presente Apesar dela querer muito o
meu avô não a deixou usar calça era
coisa de homem minha voz só usou causa
depois que meu avô faleceu foi quando
ela também teve os documentos
e eu não conheci meu avô e não me lembro
da minha avó de saia na história As
Mulheres sempre usavam saias ou vestidos
os homens usavam calça com bolso porque
as coisas de valor ficavam com eles no
bolso como dinheiro por exemplo os em
calças usem bolsos carregue com você
seus valores não os dentes na mão dos
outros
É nesse espaço do Canvas dia com seus
valores eu eim sou inteligente
determinada
resiliente vitoriosa e múltipla
o número dois
espaço número 2 do câmbio do
protagonismo feminino de o dinheiro na
mão das mulheres indique mulheres pague
o preço que uma mulher cobra para de
pedir que ela faça de graça o que ela
faz para viver contrato mulheres uma vez
um ex-chefe meu achou o carro projeto
orçado com a minha empresa eu me lembro
bem da reunião de apresentação da
proposta ele marcou eu fui ele não
prestou atenção ao vez comentário que
deixou ali ficavam nosso trabalho ele
não estava pronto para uma mulher eles
estagiário no mesmo nível que
não sei até que ponto fez isso
conscientemente acredito que não fez nós
somos impregnados da não igualdade de
gênero mesmo sem perceber antes eu
passei um projeto para a empresa dele
três vezes mais caro mas no final das
contas fui eu foi meu e eu passei um
projeto para um homem e calma não tem
nenhum problema é isso o problema está
em cogitava nunca cogitaram os mulheres
para muitos projetos inclusive nós
mulheres fazemos isso mesmo sem perceber
passo projeto para mulheres
número 3 ou são as mulheres Quais são as
principais reivindicações das mulheres
que fazem parte do seu ciclo homens ou
são as mulheres mulheres fazem alto até
que vocês não precisem mais levar Listen
reivindicações que vocês encontram as
dores não ter a mesma importância
profissional que um homem aparência vir
antes da competência abuso de poder
assédio
número 4 envolva-se politicamente list
projetos que promovam protagonismo
feminino
precisamos de mulheres em posições
estratégicas entre as crianças e 13
deputados eleitos hoje a
436 são homens e apenas 77 São mulheres
na câmera
e o governo da Argentina acabou de
reconhecer o trabalho das Mães como
página Trabalho
pela criação de cada filho mamãe poderá
ter até três anos de serviço contatos
para aposentadoria nas pesquisas que eu
vim subir protagonismo feminino muitas
mães destacaram que o essencial para
essa vitória é mãe estão bem terem
salários isso é muito forte é importante
garantir que as mulheres estejam
envolvidas politicamente em cargos
políticos legislando criando leis de
proteção à mulher
o número 5 de em voz para as mulheres
sítio mulheres As quais você gostaria de
dar voz
Quantos homens aqui divulgar um trabalho
da esposa e da mãe e da namorada
tira chefe e da colega de trabalho e da
filha Lich essas mulheres homens abram
as redes de vocês para as mulheres
contrate uma mulher para fazer uma
palestra da sua empresa e de voz a elas
número 6 lidera em outras mulheres que
mulheres você pode se inspirar
eu te ajudar a se tornar Líder
liderar não é sobre aumentar a
quantidade de seguidores é sobre
inspirar e formar novos líderes e você
sempre vai esperar alguém que meninas
você pode ajudar a transformar numa
Inter em que mulher e você pode se
esperar
o site mistura e x como abrir o debate
do protagonismo feminino para todos o
cão vejo protagonismo feminino é para
elas e para eles não sejam time só de
mulheres a gente precisa ensinar para o
outro Quando pensamos em gênero por
exemplo a tendência abordar somente o
feminino o trans ou não binário quando
masculino também precisa ser abordado Se
queremos mudar algo precisamos de falar
para todas todas todas eu não preciso
mudar que já acredita em mim precisamos
atingir outros grupos outros gêneros
para que eles estão bem levanta e a
bandeira do direito ao protagonismo da
mulher o nicho nos protege e blinda o
que é maravilhoso mas não muda o mundo
como você pode começar começar essa
mistura como você pode promover esse
movimento através de em empresas e
organizações sobre protagonismo feminino
debate sobre protagonismo feminino
elegendo mulheres para cargos políticos
por exemplo
a número 8 O Melhor de Mim Esse é o
último quadro do campo 2 do protagonismo
feminino Eu gosto do número 8 ele
infinito como a mulher Eu tenho oito
cachorros sim oito
Nossa Quantos cachorros como você dá
conta de tudo isso e quantas vezes a
gente ouvir expressões assim sendo
mulher a oitava casa sobre você o que
você pode melhorar nas suas ações para
impregnar se nesse movimento do
protagonismo feminino como gênero
masculino talvez você possa cobrar menos
e ajudar mais as mulheres da sua família
combater o racismo mesmo quando as
mulheres não estão presentes divulgar o
protagonismo das mulheres com mulher
você pode acreditar na sua voz lutar por
ela ser uma líder e ajudar uma mulher a
virar uma Líder divulgar o protagonismo
de outras mulheres esse espaço
e
a minha avó faleceu no Dia das Mães na
panelinha de convite na última conversa
que ela teve comigo ela falou sobre o
fim do meu casamento minha pretinha era
como ela me chamava a sua mãe as suas
avós passaram muita coisa para você
chegar até aqui não repita os mesmos
erros liberte-se as mulheres da minha
vida às me Trouxeram até esse palco
enfrentar um violência dificuldade de
acesso à educação ausência de poder
econômico de identidade de vós todos nós
vivemos mulheres que nos levaram até
aqui ouvir as suas histórias é evitar
repetir os mesmos erros
e quando ainda era uma menina a minha
mãe fazia uma formação em arteterapia
ela pediu para que o representasse a
minha família através de desenhos de
símbolos no meu desenho a minha mãe a
mulher forte eu representei como o raio
Ela é Luz ilumina bem Acima das nossas
cabeças e eu também estão dozza faz
barulho minha irmã era um ursinho frágil
e fofinho e eu precisava estar ali perto
dela protegendo-a hoje surcin se
transformou numa ursa forte mamãe
gigante meu pai era um robô na ponta da
folha com um homem de cifrão afastado da
gente ele sempre trabalhou muito e
durante muito muito tempo foi essa
imagem que passou para mim um pai
distante que só pensava em dinheiro meu
pai hoje está sentado me assistindo e
alguns anos meu canal é a tela de
abertura do computador dele de alguma
forma ele vem se propondo a olhar a
ouvir e dar voz
eu apresentei como uma árvore protegendo
a minha irmã abaixo da mamãe metade raiz
metade com asas minha mãe me perguntou
porque eu fiz assim meio árvore meio
passa
e eu respondi que era porque metade de
mim queria ficar sempre com elas ser
família a outra metade queria voar mundo
afora conquistar novas fronteiras ter
meus próprios negócios ser livre por aí
Há muitos pratinhos minha mãe ensinou
que é importante olhar para as meninas
antes mesmo delas serem mulheres eu
perguntei ficou bom mamãe minha mãe
olhou para mim e disse tá ótimo minha
filha o importante é você ser livre para
ser você esse é o meu desejo hoje que
todas as meninas e mulheres gozem a
liberdade de ser
Livres obrigada